[Musik]
[Applaus]
es ist märz und die tage werden endlich
wieder länger und
[Musik]
nicht nur bringen gerade ganz viel zeit
im garten und bereitet die beete vor und
macht die ersten ausfahrten
[Musik]
so ein frisch vorbereitetes beet
erinnert mich immer an eine blanke
leinwand die bemalt werden möchte mit
bunten gemüse tupfen und leuchtenden
blumen und duftenden kräutern und ich
kann es kaum abwarten bis sich wieder
mit prall gefüllten ernte körben in die
küche laufen kann und bis der ein
kochtopf wieder rund um die uhr auf dem
herd ruckelt und bis mir die arme weh
tun von dem ganzen sommer graut es sich
gestampft habe
[Musik]
seit dem letzten story video ist eine
ganze menge passiert also fangen wir am
besten am anfang an im februar als wir
bekommen haben
[Musik]
wir haben keinen haben deswegen können
wir dafür nicht unsere eigenen eier
nehmen und weil keiner der hendrick wild
musste der brut automat ran
das dauert ungefähr 21 tage bis aus
einem ei geschlüpft
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt seit ungefähr anderthalb
stunden am koppeln und das ein stück
zaun war ungefähr so lang ist wie normal
dass schaafs netz also nicht besonders
lang und ich habe schon eine ganze rolle
draht verkoppelt beziehungsweise litze
und jetzt ist sie auch noch leer kurz
bevor ich fertig bin eine ganze rolle
anderthalb stunden
lang
das ist auch keine lösung jetzt im
winter geht das mal wo die ziegen nicht
so oft umziehen wie im sommer aber im
sommer ist das einfach gar nicht machbar
so lange ich kein eigenes grundstück
habe und meine ziegen immer auf den
grundstücken von anderen leuten beiden
brauche ich mobile zäune der nachteil an
den mobilen schaafs netzen ist aber dass
ziegen wenn sie mal abhauen wollen und
kleine randnotiz siegen wollen
eigentlich auf und abbauen dass sie sich
dabei im zaun strangulieren können
allerdings kann ich hier auch keine
festen zäune bauen und deswegen habe ich
versucht eine andere art von zorn zu
baue ich habe zum glück nach plätze
gefunden jetzt ist nur die große frage
wo der anfang ist
[Musik]
wie vor auch so dringend einen eigenen
bauernhof mit festen zeiten wo ich das
nicht mehr machen muss und wo keine züge
in diesen blöden elektronischen bleibt
manchmal wenn ich so ein esel die
nächste anschaffung wird definitiv eine
kabeltrommel
das ist bla bla
[Musik]
dieses geräusch ist geschafft
ja und dann war es auf einmal so weit
und mein buch wurde gedruckt wenn wir
das vor fünf jahren jemand gesagt hätte
dann hätte ich das nie geglaubt dass ich
mal so ein wunderschönes cooles buch
über selbstversorgung schreiben würde
das war ein unglaubliches gefühl zu
sehen wie dieses baby entsteht
[Musik]
wir sind auf dem weg in die dritte reihe
und als die julia vom löwenzahn verleiht
[Musik]
und deswegen waren wir in österreich zu
gast bei der druckerei klar das ist eine
ganz tolle druckerei die mit
pflanzenfarben druck sodass das komplett
biologisch abbaubar ist und es sollte
drei beeindruckend zu sehen wie eine
seite nach der anderen durch die
maschine fliegt und ja wann toller
vorgeschmack darauf wie das buch wohl
später aussehen will ins gebunden ist
[Musik]
und die dritte reihe hat er sogar auch
einen gemüsegarten
ich bin ich der größte garten spanner
wenn ich irgendwo gelesen
dann hänge ich als erstes über den zaun
das buch musste nach dem druck erst noch
gebunden werden aber als ich wieder zu
hause war hat es gar nicht lange
gedauert bis er ein paketbote stand mit
einem ganz ganz tollen paket
okay
[Musik]
von dem paar tage später ist das buch
dann auch offiziell erschienen und die
vorstellung dass jetzt gerade ganz viele
von euch in das buch vertieft sind in
darin lesen ist einfach abgefahren und
total cool also ganz viel spaß und alle
die lust haben mir über selbst
versorgungs lernen nicht nur über
gemüseanbau sondern auch über hühner
über brotbacken sauerkraut herstellen
und alles was dazugehört und danke an
alle für die tolle unterstützung das war
keine zwei tage draußen und schon stand
überall bestseller dran und
eine korrekte vorstellung also ganz ganz
viel spaß beim lesen wenn ihr das buch
über mich bestellen wollt dann schaut in
die video beschreibung da habe ich echt
link gepostet und dann war mein garten
auf einmal bevölkert von lauter
kameramännern und ton leuten und
regisseuren und sogar eine stylistin war
da die nur dafür zuständig war mich zu
schminken und dafür zu sorgen dass meine
haare immer sitzen weil ich nämlich in
einer youtube kampagne eines der
gesichter bin dh es kann gut sein wenn
ihr demnächst mal mit der u bahn fahrrad
oder mit dem bus dass ihr dann mein
gesicht auf einer großen plakatwand
sieht ziemlich verrückt irgendwie mal
gucken ob ich irgendwann mal 1 zuließen
plakaten sie hier und wie sich das dann
anfühlt
königl
die mobilen dienste
auf dem foto sollte ich so aussehen als
ob die kehle und das hat sich auch kein
bisschen bescheuert angefühlt die ganze
zeit zu tun wäre ein zehn leute um einen
herum stehen und einen anschauen
[Musik]
vielleicht